depuis un mois le docteur Libermann et
son équipe du chôme se prépare pour une
première norme américaine en traitement
du cancer du poumon jusqu'ici ils ont
réalisé une vingtaine de biopsies sur
des patients qui présentent des
métastases maintenant ils sont prêts
pour l'étape suivante détruire leur
tumeur mais sans utiliser un scalpel ni
version une goutte de sang qu'on a un
nouveau robot bronchoscopique donc une
robot qui va aller dans la bouche la
patient avec une caméra miniature que
l'on peut contrôler sur une contrôleur
comme une xbox et avec cette robot on
rentre dans le poumon on trouve le
tumeur et on va le tuer sans ce jeu
l'appareil est une merveille de
technologie l’équipe soignante doit
d'abord repérer et marquer le site des
tumeurs qu'on veut éliminer des poumons
du patient si vous imaginez le poumon
c'est comme un arbre donc on a le
trachée qui est comme le tronc puis
après on a tous les branches mais les
tumeurs se trouvent dans les feuilles
une salle d'opération le chirurgien est
aux commandes mais c'est le robot qui
accomplit tout le travail manuel il sait
où se trouve la cible et connaît le plus
court trajet pour s'y rendre c'est comme
une système de navigation comme Waze ou
Google Maps une fois la cible atteinte
on utilise un scalpel à micro-ondes pour
détruire les tumeur au final
l'intervention est rapide et les
dommages très limités le patient rentre
le matin quitte l'après-midi ils peuvent
retourner un travail le lendemain puis
il perd une minime partie de son poumon
vraiment juste la tumeur et un peu de
poumon tour le robot a été développé au
Québec par quinova et son partenaire
américain Johnson et Johnson il est
conçu pour servir d'extension aux mains
du chirurgien et pour les optimiser ce
qu'on vient faire c'est rajouter des
couches de protection donc empêcher les
perforations empêchées d'appliquer trop
de force on va guider un petit peu on va
accompagner l'utilisation mais c'est le
chirurgien qui est en contrôle et sont
en contrôle en tout temps si tous des
routes bien durant l'essai clinique qui
Nova a déjà plusieurs projets sur sa
planche dessin présentement la priorité
c'est vraiment les poumons mais pensez-y
un peu comme le scalpel qui est utilisé
dans la majorité des interventions mais
le scalpel de demain va être robotisé
pour les patients comme pour les
chirurgiens on est peut-être en train de
tourner une page importante c'est encore
le médecin qui contrôle le robot mais
une jour ça va venir où les médecins
sont pas impliqués dans ces
procédures-là et probablement les robots
avec l'intelligence artificielle va être
mieux que nous puis on souhaite ça pour
les patients ici normand Grondin
Radio-Canada Montréal